[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec Gaïa l'entourage aussi la suivre à
nous toutes ces années ils ont dit noir
et blanc voilà c'est maman toujours dit
Mika Tana reconnaissance de mon pays
plus que aller faire la star
internationale et aujourd'hui voilà mon
petit théâtre pour moi c'est un
reconnaissance enfin de toute le travail
que nous l'a fait donc déjà on a deux
générations c'est manga vol donc
l'ancienne équipe a fait 23 ans avec ses
manga vol qui sera présent avec la
nouvelle génération il fait deux ans on
est là
on aura maloya dans le corps c'est plus
d'une vingtaine de danseurs sur scène
avec moi
et que la vie aussi une influence
pour moi sera un moment important
d'émotion déjà personnellement voilà ma
commence la musique m'avait 16 17 ans et
personne te croit pas trop mais tu es
chante ma belle frère tu fais chante à
moi et c'est surtout mon papa que la
pousse à moi
à faire de la musique et à aller plus
loin et à dépasser moins chaque fois et
tout le temps l'été dernièrement ça
couvert va greffer sa couvert va griffer
et voilà aujourd'hui ben le concert il
est extrêmement commun c'est vraiment
poli aussi surtout
[Musique]
à nous fendre c'est vrai que
les pas toujours facile de d'évoluer
dans ce milieu là parce que ben voilà
n'allez tous les stéréotypes le font les
moments les femmes les femmes dans tout
ça là il faut surmonter pour que avoir
un parcours tel que nous viennent là et
puis mais voilà nous voudrez dire à
toutes les nouvelles générations et
surtout toute belle nouvelle manifie une
jeune fille qui grandit et qu'il veut
traverser dans la culture donne maloya
il faut tenir ensemble il faut se battre
les possibles après avoir
[Musique]